i'm haram i'm one of the fellows here
for this uh semester
um i'm gonna be the chair for this
session and uh let's hear it from
from ut austin on competitive analysis
meets stochastic input segregated
problems and profit
thank you
so let me start uh
this discussion with a motivating
problem
uh so here's a very uh sort of uh
standard problem that comes up uh in the
context of
uh serving ads to customers on some
online platform so imagine you go on
google and search for tennis shoes
google needs to figure out which ads to
show you and there are advertisers that
uh bid
uh on these ad slots and let's say
google's objective is to pick the the
highest bid and to you know maximize the
sum of the bids will keep it very simple
now the problem is that uh you know when
you decide which ad to serve you don't
know who's going to show up next
so
so uh yeah and let's say that you have
some constraints on how often you can
serve uh any particular ad so here let's
say each advertiser can be served just
once for this really simple example then
we don't know which one to pick
necessarily for the first
shopper that
arrives without knowing who is going to
arrive next okay so this is uh this is a
simple
online bipartite matching problem where
our goal is to maximize the total weight
of the matching okay so
sort of a toy problem but uh rooted in
uh some kind of some you know
real world system that needs to you know
solve this sort of problem okay and as
you can see uh in this example here uh
you know these requests for uh ads are
arriving over time and if we are in the
situation that anupam talked about this
morning which is this online setup and
we don't know what's to arrive in the
future then this is basically a hopeless
problem because you never know when you
might get a very very high value uh
or very high weight uh set of edges
okay and here's an even simpler uh setup
for this so imagine you're a you're an
uber driver and you want to pick one you
know select uh sort of serve one
customer on your shift
and customers arrive over time and
there's some uh you know profit you get
from serving any particular customer and
if they arrive in an online fashion uh
you know as soon as you pick one
your shift is done but you sort of need
to make this decision uh of accept or
reject when each customer arrives
without knowing who else will come in
the future
okay so basically the upshot is that
this is uh in the worst case this is a
pretty hopeless problem uh to solve if
we don't have any information about the
future and this is quite unlike the kind
of settings anupam talked about this uh
morning uh and uh you know he very
briefly pointed out this difference
between
uh you know sort of covering problems in
the online uh context and and packing
problems so this is a packing problem
and uh it's it's basically uh hopeless
uh without any further information
so uh
you know keeping with the
theme of
keeping with the theme of uh this
program what we want to do is to figure
out how we can incorporate data within
uh these uh
in the context of these problems in
order to be able to make some progress
and you know the the the uh uh
the
probably the best uh or the strongest
way of doing this might be to assume
that you have enough data to
know precisely the stochastic model from
which your input is drawn and if you
were able to do that you know then we
can you know at least the problem is now
well formulated given this stochastic
model what is my best policy uh never
mind computational aspects but at least
in terms of formulating the problem you
could imagine solving this uh but you
know for the worst case we saw that uh
this is too pessimistic and uh you know
even if we could design an algorithm the
algorithm would be tuned to uh you know
worst case and uh maybe unrealistic
instances uh and so
that's not a great idea and on the other
hand this other extreme can also be uh
too strong of an extreme it's too
optimistic to assume we will have this
entire model and on the other hand uh if
we were to design an algorithm for a
given model this would be a brittle uh
algorithm it would not be robust to
potential changes uh in the model or uh
you know errors you might have made in
in coming up with the model so what we
want to explore is some middle ground
where uh you know we take uh sort of
aspects of both of these uh extremes uh
we can be robust to
uh how we model uh the input while at
the same time uh you know obtaining a
tractable problem where we can make some
uh uh you know good algorithmic insights
and come up with some interesting
algorithms so there are a number of
different uh kinds of uh you know
semi-random models i'll describe a few
approaches and then we'll talk about two
particular ones uh in this talk
and uh i should say that you have this
idea of coming up with semi-random
models it's an old idea but then uh
theoretical computer science has been
explored for several decades
but more recently there's been a renewed
interest in this topic uh partly because
of these very nice applications that
arise in the context of
economics and and mechanism design these
are settings where the worst case
is uh completely hopeless whereas the
stochastic completely stochastic setting
is fairly well understood in various
contexts and so it makes sense it gives
us very fertile ground for exploring
different kinds of semi-random models
and
and coming up with some interesting
techniques there
okay so what sorts of models can we uh
imagine so you could imagine uh you know
you don't have the entire
input model but you know something about
the distribution maybe you have some
core statistics that you can use to
design an algorithm
or alternately uh you know maybe you
don't know the input distribution but
you know that it belongs to some nice
class like iid models for instance would
be that kind of a
semi-random
setup
another uh possibility is that we don't
know the model but we do have sample
access we've seen past instances of it
uh and in this talk i will focus on the
the last line i mentioned here which is
that there's some amount of
stochasticity in your input but there's
also some amount of some adversarial
component to the input and
we'll talk more
about this
there are various other
things there are models
with where you have predictions about
the input and so on so this is not an
exhaustive list
and just two places in context anupam of
course talked about the purely worst
case this morning and ellen is going to
talk about
the sample access
setting and will be in this part
stochastic part adversarial context for
this talk
okay
so that was the 10 000 foot view uh let
me now talk about the uh specific
problems we'll discuss uh in this talk
uh so we'll we'll talk about uh what
i'll broadly call online selection
problems uh so we're gonna have here n
elements that will arrive in some
sequence every element will have a
weight and what we're interested in
doing is making accept project decisions
on these so think of the you know uber
driver uh setting where for every
customer you're deciding whether to
accept the ride or not
and uh our goal will be to maximize the
total weight of the accepted elements
under the constraint that the set we
accept satisfies some uh feasibility
constraint it's going to be downwards
closed um meaning that uh uh
you know if i can accept the set then i
can also accept some subset of that
okay so that's the kind of problem we'll
think about
and the uber driver setting is what i'll
call the single unit case you're
accepting only one
of the given elements uh the um ad slot
setting i described is a little bit
different here because the what we have
here is like a bipartite graph and
what's arriving are these vertices or
these shoppers uh on the right
and every time a shopper arrives we
don't just accept or reject them but we
figure out which edge to match right so
it's it's more general than just an
accept project uh decision so this is
what i'll call online resource
allocation and it's it's a little bit
more general than online selections
we'll talk about this
uh but we'll also uh talk about
matching where the elements are the
edges that are arriving over time and
again we're making accept reject
decisions
okay so these kinds of problems have
been studied for many different kinds of
feasibility constraints two others that
i'll mention today are meteoroids which
if you don't know what metroid's are
it's okay because we won't really go
into that in this talk but it's a
setting that's been studied quite
extensively
and then the k unit case which is like a
single unit except now you can select up
to k
of the arriving elements okay so these
are some examples of the kinds of
settings
we can imagine here
so what about the
semi-random model
uh so notice that there are two aspects
to an instance here there are
there's the order in which the elements
arrive and there's the weight that each
element has
and we're going to consider two
different settings where one of these is
stochastic and the other is adversarial
so the secretary problem is a setting
where the weights of the elements are
completely adversarial we know nothing
about them
to begin with
and we observe these weights as we
observe the elements
but the arrival order over the elements
is uniformly random okay
and the alternative setting we'll look
at is what's called the profit
inequality setting
here the weights are drawn from known
distributions but the arrival order is
unknown ahead of time you can think of
this as being adversarial
but really for the algorithms we design
we won't even need to know what the
arrival order is ahead of time
and these are both problems that
were studied you know decades back
within optimal stopping theory and
there's seen this renewed interest
in these settings because of connections
to
mechanism design i won't elaborate on
that really
okay
so we're we're bridging this worst case
with the stochastic setting by bringing
in these elements of uh adversarial
input and stochastic
stochasticity so we're still going to
continue to use the concept of
competitive ratio to measure the quality
of our algorithms so this time around uh
we'll again take the the ratio of the
optimum to the algorithm and this uh i'm
calling this benchmark hindsight opt
because hindsight opt is uh an algorithm
that can view the entire uh input and in
hindsight figures out what to have done
and we're gonna you know so hindsight
opt-in algorithm are both going to face
the same randomness in the input so
we'll take the ratio of the expectations
of these quantities
and then whatever adversarial components
the input has will
maximize the ratio over that okay so
that's uh
uh our benchmark
and uh so let's uh just quickly note
that
for the secondary problem setting in the
single unit case where we're only
accepting one element the hindsight
optimum is just the maximum weight
over all the elements uh same for the
profit inequality except now we plug in
you know we take the
okay expectation that's what we are
competing against
is the model clear to everyone any
questions
okay and so the upshot is that i said
that in the purely worst case setting
these problems are hopeless but it'll
turn out that
under these uh parts stochastic part
adversarial models these turn out to be
quite tractable and they'll admit
constant competitive ratios in many
different settings
and so what i want to do in this talk is
to give you uh just some uh
an overview of some of the different
techniques that are that go into uh
developing
these algorithms and what the analysis
look like
okay so we'll start with the profit
inequality setting
and uh we'll start with the simple
single unit case
and so here's just a little example uh
you know to understand what the instance
looks like
so we know uh that we're gonna get let's
say three elements and we know ahead of
time that uh that the first element is
going to have a weight which is one with
one half probability and two with one
half probability for the second element
we have a different distribution over
weight we know this distribution as well
the third element we know the
distribution okay and the question we're
asking is when the first element shows
up uh you know its weight is
instantiated we observe the weight so
maybe uh you know this turns out to be
two and the question is should we accept
it or not okay uh knowing uh this model
for the future arrivals
okay and then maybe at this point we
decide to reject it and we go to the
second element
it gets instantiated as one should be
accepted or not and so on
okay and one of the things uh you should
see immediately is uh you know if i know
the order in which the elements are
arriving
i can you know figure out what my policy
should be by doing backwards induction
but that's not what i want to do because
uh i want to actually understand how
let's say that optimal backwards
induction solution how does that compare
to the the hindsight opt
right so you know doing backwards
induction doesn't give me intuition for
that
okay and furthermore if i didn't know
the order and all i see is the first
element but i don't know uh you know
which of the other two is going to
arrive next then the backwards induction
approach doesn't quite work
okay so that's the issue
so so we don't want to do backwards
induction but nevertheless we can at
least understand what the hindsight
optimum looks like because the hindsight
optimum doesn't depend on the order
okay no matter what order they arrive in
it just picks the maximum of the
instantiated baits okay so one of the
things we could do is to ask well what
is the likelihood that
that
okay so one of the things we could ask
is what is the probability that the
hindsight optimum selects the first guy
or selects the second guy or the third
guy and let me call this x i
and
if we know these we can just write down
hindsight opt in this fashion it's sum
over i
of x i times the the weight that the
ith guy has
conditioned on being accepted by off and
we can certainly do that here so i can
ask you know what is the probability
that this guy is the highest uh you know
it's the probability that this is at
five and uh
you know it doesn't matter what the
others are at so this is clearly one
quarter
and then i can ask what is the
probability that this guy is the highest
so now this uh you know depending on
whether the value is two or three i can
do a little calculation i can calculate
these given the distributions
so now here's the idea that we're going
to implement we're gonna try to uh you
know mimic in our algorithm these
optimal probabilities okay so what do i
mean by that so when the first element
arrives i know what this x1 is i'm going
to accept this element with probability
x1
okay uh but i only want to accept the
higher the you know x1 highest quantiles
uh of this element i want to do the best
possible with that x1 constraint so how
do i do this uh well i'm going to just
compute some threshold p1
uh
such that the probability that the w1 is
uh greater than equal to t1 this is
precisely x1 so these are the top x1
quantiles for this
element
okay and observe that uh you know i've
selected this element with probability
x1 i'm selecting this element with
probability x1 but i'm just focusing on
the highest x1 quantiles so my
expected weight condition on selecting
it is at least as large as the opt's
expected weight from this element
condition on selecting it
okay so that's great
and then if i don't select this element
i go to element 2 and now i want to
accept element 2 with probability x2 and
i can do the same thing
so i'll find some threshold d2 such that
this probability is is exactly extruded
and i'll keep doing
this and so if i do this i can write
down the the total weight the algorithm
yes or the expected weight algorithm
gets
as the sum over i
of uh well there's the probability that
the algorithm even reaches the if person
because he might have already accepted
something before
okay
times this x i this is the probability
that i accept the it think times this
expected weight condition on accepting
and we already said that this quantity
is at least as large as that quantity up
there
okay and so really then the question is
you know this term here
what can i say about this term what is
the probability that the algorithm is
even going to reach
okay
and in general this quantity could be
very tiny so for instance if x1 is like
90 percent
okay you're you're happy that you uh you
know just like opt you accept the first
person with 90 probability but maybe x2
is uh uh so you know let me just
write this down so
if uh
let's say my example was such that you
know x1 was 90 percent and x2 was 10
um you know i accept the first guy with
probability 90
but the second one i get to it with
probability uh you know ten percent and
then i uh accept it with probability ten
percent so this
is much smaller than this potentially
okay so that that's a problem so i don't
know i can't quite directly compare the
two
quantities
okay so what can we do to fix this well
it turns out that there's a really
simple fix to this
so instead of accepting the if element
with probability x i
i'm going to leave some probability on
the table for future elements i'm only
going to accept it with probability x i
over 2.
again i'll adjust my thresholds
accordingly
and now my thresholds are higher
so it's still the case that condition on
accepting the element i'm doing better
than not
okay but now what happens is if you
think about element i
before this element there was an x i or
x one over two probability of having
stopped at the first step
and then
uh an x two over two probability uh
maybe less than that of stopping at the
second step x 3 over 2 for the third
step and so on
and so the total probability that i
stopped before getting to element i
is no more than this sum here which is
at most one half because you know the x
is sum up to one it's the probability
that opt selects uh element
so just by you know leaving this one
half on the table i'm assured that
i'm going to reach every element
with some constant probability
and this term becomes at least one half
so i lose a factor of one-half here i
lose a factor of one-half here
this gives uh gives us a four
competitive uh algorithm for this
problem
and in fact we can make this analysis a
little bit tighter so i can you know
adjust the thresholds in such a way that
the that for any element i the
probability that we reach the element
and accept it that entire event happens
with the probability x i over 2. so what
i'm going to do when i reach element i
is i'll compute the probability that i
actually got there given what i saw
before
and i'm going to so let's say this is
alpha i i'm going to set the threshold
so that my probability of acceptance is
now x i over 2 alpha i so that you know
these terms now
they
multiply to to give me x i over two this
is the probability i reach i times the
probability i accepted condition on
reaching
and as before
this alpha i is at least one half
okay so in fact condition on reaching
uh element i
i'm accepting it with probability no
more than x i
so
the expected uh weight i get from
element i conditioned on accepting it is
still higher than what ops
gets
okay and so this gives us uh at least
one half of what we have up there
okay and this one have for this setting
turns out to be tight
and
here is a simple example showing this so
we just have two
elements the first one has a weight of
one
with probability one the second one has
a weight of one over epsilon with
probability epsilon and zero otherwise
and now it doesn't matter whether you
decide to accept or reject the first
element if you accept it you get a
weight of one if you reject it in
expectation you still get a weight of
one from the second guy
but the optimum is going to take the
second element with probability epsilon
and its weight is one over epsilon and
with probability one minus epsilon it's
going to take the first element so it's
gonna have
the expected weight uh close to two
again
so what i mean is i haven't accepted
someone else before
okay so the basically what's going to
happen is you know you see the first guy
if you accept
the first element the process ends
because you can only accept that
no it's it's at least
half
the probability that you
reach an element is going to be at least
one half because uh the probability you
stopped earlier is you know x one over
two plus x two over two
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
they actually
so yeah um
i'm not entirely sure to me you're not
really
uh you know giving a boost or changing
the distributions the question is just
what it uh you know you're trying to
figure out how many of the top quantiles
for each distribution you're going to
accept
and what we're saying is we for every
element we don't want this to be any
more than x i because opt does x i but
we also don't want this to be any uh
smaller than x i over two oh no i
understand so what
is the corresponding threshold for
another distribution
which has uh which is
which gives you more reward right
okay
yeah so uh yes so you could ask you know
what if i i accept each element with
probability exactly x i
uh right so this is what you're saying
so instead of um
x i over two i do x i so
um
yeah i mean one could
try to play around with this and and i'm
gonna you know describe just a general
scheme for for this but i'm not sure
what you mean by boosting distribution
maybe we can talk about it
okay so here's another example of this
this time we'll talk about matchings so
now we have a graph
and the elements that are arriving are
edges in this graph and every time an
edge arrives we decide whether to accept
it or not and our constraint is we want
to maintain a matching
okay
and so once again we will uh compute the
uh probabilities x i
that
op selects any edge i
and uh we're gonna now again come up
with a collision avoidance uh algorithm
that forever that you know uh tries to
mimic these probabilities but uh you
know with a slight factor less so that
you know we still retain enough uh
likelihood of of uh you know reaching
any particular element that will arrive
in the future so this time around what
we're going to do is
when element i arrives
we will accept it uh you know if it's
still feasible to accept the element
we'll accept it with probability x i
over 3 will come up with the
corresponding threshold and once again i
can write down the algorithm's
total weight as a sum over i of the
probability that uh you know it's still
feasible for me to accept the edge i
when it arrives
times this x i over 3 times this
expected weight condition on accepting
and once again this quantity is going to
be at least as large as
what opt gets conditioned on accepting i
so again the question is you know what
is this probability that uh edge i
remains unblocked when we see this edge
and we can write this down as follows so
edge i is going to remain unblocked as
long as neither of its endpoints have
been matched yet
okay and if i look at uh one of the
endpoints of this edge then opt accepted
you know only one edge incident on this
endpoint so the sum of the x's
corresponding to those edges is at most
one and even if we've seen all of those
edges before i the total probability we
might have accepted one of them is is at
most you know the sum of those x's
divided by three so i get at most of one
third
uh
for that
blocking probability and likewise for
the second endpoint basically the same
thing
and so i lose this this one third two
times for each of the end points and i'm
still left over with this one-third
probability of of the edge being
unblocked
a fairly simple uh idea
and so we can put all of this together
and
we lose a factor of 3 here factor of 3
here we get at least a 9th of the
optimal value
again of course it's it's possible to to
tune these and do this in a
more clever manner to get a better
factor out but the the upshot is that uh
you know you can get some constant
fraction of the optimal
and so
all of this hints to towards
a more
general approach for solving
these kinds of problems and this is
what's called an online contention
resolution scheme and i'll
describe
what this is uh it was first proposed
for offline
rounding
by chakuri at all and then in the online
context it was proposed by feldman
stenson and zinklezen and ola is here
one of the authors on on this work
uh and uh
you know basically uh
you know this was proposed as a way of
obtaining uh constant factor
uh competitive ratios for for profit
inequalities so what uh
a cocrs does is it's given this
you know fractional solution x for how
the hindsight optimum
accepts the different elements and then
it provides a procedure an online
procedure for determining when you get
to a particular element
in this space
it tells us the probability with which
we ought to be accepting this element if
it remains unblocked okay and the goal
is to do this in such a way that
the net probability of accepting any
particular element is going to be at
least some
fraction
of this x i some c times x i and that's
the c that shows up over there
and furthermore we also want it to be
the case that every element uh when we
arrive at it
it remains unblocked with probability at
least c so that the threshold we set for
it is going to be you know the
probability we accept this element
condition on it being unblocked is going
to be no more than x i and if we can
ensure all of that then uh
the the same uh
kind of analysis i showed you before for
writing down the algorithm's total
weight gives us a c approximation here
okay so basically if we can design a
cocrs this gives us a c competitive
profit inequality
and these have been studied for
many different
uh
feasibility constraints here are two
examples so allay showed that if you
have uh k
if you can accept up to k elements then
you can design this
ocrs so that you get a 1 minus 1 over
root k plus 3 fraction of the total
weight and note that when k is one this
is precisely one half
and as k increases this steadily gets
closer and closer to one uh and this
turns out to be the asymptotically
optimal
um competitive ratio for this setting
and feldman and i'll show that you can
design a one-half ocrs for metroids and
then there are further results known for
metroid intersections improvements for
the matching setting that i showed
before and so on so i won't go into the
details of these but i just wanted to
describe this general scheme
yeah so um i mean you could compute x i
through something for example
uh okay so you could say
let's draw a bunch of samples so this is
uh you know just looking at uh you know
what is the uh
probability that i belongs to an optimal
solution right so you could sample and
compute these
do you understand the limitation of this
approach are there settings where you
know this
style of algorithm can't possibly work
okay so very good question this is going
to be my next point so we said that if
you could design an ocrs then you can
get a profit inequality and in fact it
turns out that
this goes in the other direction as well
and i say essentially because it goes in
the other direction if you have a c
competitive profit and equality against
a slightly stronger benchmark
um
which is called the the exante
relaxation so it's it's the benchmark
where here you basically have the
uh
expected wi condition on wi being among
the x i highest quantiles okay so if i
just replace this with something like
this
you know and if i can get a c
approximation against that slightly
stronger benchmark then in fact it turns
out that there's also a cocrs so these
are essentially equivalent and uh you
know designing profit inequalities is
basically the same thing as designing uh
an ocrs
just to clarify c-o-c-r-s's always are
sequential against that stronger
benchmark we just yes yes
because i could basically you know just
replace yeah so it's it's really like
the um
uh corresponding term is this one
but ocrs are not the only way we do we
know how to design profit inequalities
so let me tell you some other
techniques that have their own strengths
and in fact it turns out that
you know the original results on profit
inequalities were really uh
combinatorial in nature and my favorite
one is uh this very nice algorithm due
to samuel khan for the
original single item a single unit
profit inequality uh it says the
following it says that we're going to
pick a single threshold
and we're just going to accept the first
element that crosses the threshold
okay and what is the threshold we pick
we're just going to find some threshold
so that there's at least one element
that will cross it with probability
one-half
so
this is
very interesting the first time you see
this because you know with one-half
probability at this threshold we're not
going to accept anything at all so the
algorithm's weight is zero
right but with one half probability
we'll accept something and this is not
necessarily even the best thing that
crosses the threshold there could be
multiple things that cross the threshold
we're just going to pick the first one
that arise
and yet it turns out that this is only
going to lose a factor of 2 relative to
the hindsight optimum
so at first glance this should not be
possible right but i'll show you an
analysis for this very neat uh
result
and uh the the proof is due to samuel
khan but i will use an economic
interpretation which is very nice
and this is due to feldman raven and
lucia and this is actually a different
feldman than the one i had on the
previous flight so
mihal feldman and that was more on
feldman so different people but uh
overlapping work
okay so what is the interpretation we're
going to think of this threshold as a
price
for um
let's say the single resource we are
selling to one of those customers and
we're picking the first person who uh uh
wants to pay this price and we're going
to look at the total reward the
algorithm or the optimum get in terms of
the revenue from selling at that price
so this is this revenue is just t if if
the unit actually sells and is zero
otherwise
and the buyer's utility which is going
to be uh you know whatever weight they
arrived with minus this price they paid
okay
so that's that's the quantity we'll look
at
and now observe that
the optimum we can just write this we
can bound it from above by
this price t let's say we give this to
the optimum all the time
plus whatever extra the optimum
gets by selling to the person with the
highest weight okay so this this plus
here just means that uh
you don't get anything if wi is smaller
than t but you get the difference if
it's larger than
and what does the algorithm get well the
algorithm gets that revenue of t if the
unit actually sells
plus
it's also going to get this difference
if if uh
for the ith element of the units uh if
the if element sells and when does the
if element sell and well when we get to
the if element
if this uh if the item is unsold
so we haven't sold it to one through i
then we're going to get this difference
because when this difference is positive
we'll sell to the if person and when
this difference is negative it doesn't
matter this term is zero
okay and so in fact we can you know take
the sum over i of these uh differences
okay
uh with the positive part of these
differences times the probability that
we haven't sold the unit
uh when we uh get to customer i
okay and now here's the really neat
trick so by the way i
there's an implicit assumption here
which is
that uh the
uh so i'm not writing expectations i
really should be writing expectations
everywhere uh but also we're going to
use the fact that this event that the
unit hasn't sold yet is independent of
the weight of the if person so those are
all independent distributions and that's
important here but now here's the the
real neat trick
well the probability that the unit
hasn't sold yet is at least as large as
the probability that the unit doesn't
sell at all
okay so it's still unsold uh until the
end and that's why we picked that one
half here we want the unit to remain
unsold until the end so that we have
enough of a chance of getting to
everyone uh and it's in some ways
similar to the ocrs i showed you before
and so we can write it in this manner
and we can really you know this is the
same quantity for every i so we can
really pull it out
and now
each of these probabilities the
probability that we sold the unit or
didn't sell each of these is one half
okay and so
we get this
lower bound on the algorithms
performance if you just compare the two
we get a factor of two
competitive ratio so this
this whole before the last step this
whole score
yes so in fact everything until the last
step holds for all t
and so it turns out that there are many
choices of p that work
one particular one is we pick a t that
you know equates these two components
another one is that we pick a t that is
one half of r and all of those work and
in fact if these different ways of
setting t give you different values you
can also pick anything within the range
and it still gives you a two competitive
algorithm so it's really really a robust
kind of
argument
and
uh there's uh you know i showed you the
the big have the heavy hammer of using
an ocrs but there are uh nice benefits
of using this sort of a combinatorial
approach because it gives a single
static threshold
it's a lot easier to say you know we're
in a setting where maybe we don't know
the distributions exactly we need to
compute one statistic
and that is this you know median of the
maximum weight and it should be much
easier to to learn uh than
uh you know an ocrs
actually much simpler
a combinatorial in the sense that it
didn't uh rely on sort of what i'm
thinking of as the lp formulation of the
problem so there was some
exante you know fractional relaxation of
the problem that gave us the x's
uh for ocrs and so i'm thinking of that
as sort of a you know rounding type of
approach it's a combinatorial
relative to that but also we'll see you
know extensions of this to other more
combinatorial settings
and the threshold is just a medium
it's just the median of the maximum
weight yes
and it also has this these
a nice fairness and incentive properties
so everybody faces the same threshold
right we don't pick different thresholds
for different elements so that's kind of
nice
okay and
it's possible to extend this to
more general settings so
for the k unit case one way to extend
this is to say that
uh you know instead of
looking at this probability you look at
the number of uh elements that cross the
threshold t
and you know let's say we said this so
we want this number to be about k but we
uh you know uh uh
set this to be slightly lower than that
for concentration bounds to kick in and
get this and this gives a 1 minus root
of log k with k
competitive ratio for the k unit case
asymptotically
and then it turns out that a slightly
different way of setting the threshold
in fact uh
you know gives uh better results for
small k
so uh in particular you know there are
these two failure modes for this profit
inequality it could be the case that we
uh you know set the threshold
too low so that all units sell out
before we've seen all customers and the
second failure mode is we set the
threshold so high that we don't sell
enough units
okay and so if you look at the expected
fraction of units unsold that's one
failure mode and then the probability
that all units are sold out that's the
second failure mode and it turns out
that if we equate these two
for any given uh instance
then this gives the exactly optimal way
of setting the thresh the static
threshold the single threshold for any k
even for small k and it has the same
asymptotic performance as this one
but you'll notice that uh you know we we
don't do as well as uh allah's ocrs so
there's a gap in fact
between
what a single uh threshold for all
elements can do and what this uh you
know uh adaptive threshold that la gave
can do yeah
yes or setting a threshold for
threshold-based algorithms or
for static thresholds yes where you pick
a single threshold yes
so the hidden constant is often
yes yes so this gives some this gives
some uh uh let's say alpha k right and
asymptotically the alpha k is that value
but in fact you know it it starts at one
half and increases gradually and that is
optimal for every game
so you know the downside of static
thresholds is they're not always optimal
okay but sometimes we know them
so basically you need to look for
sort of
to keep this like if these like specials
like one over k or something like that
right
so you mean in terms of how many you
want to sell
yeah yeah so roughly speaking what's
going to end up happening is that the
the fraction of units you sell is going
to
asymptotically
you know
be precisely this for the worst case
instance but for some instances maybe
you do better than that
and then there's a different extension
of samuel khan's approach that i want to
uh mention and this is uh due to
kleinberg and weinberg for the metroid
setting and and they uh looked at the
following extension so i said here that
you could set the threshold to be one
half of this expected maximum weight
uh and kleinberg and weinberg suggest
the following approach for setting the
threshold for element i they say well
let's look at the opportunity cost of
accepting this element so meaning we
could ask you know what is the
op what is the expected value hindsight
optimum could collect
this point onwards
uh if i accept element i versus if i
don't accept element i you can look at
the difference of those and that's the
opportunity cost of accepting i
and if you set the threshold to be one
half of that
they call these balanced thresholds this
turns out to give a true approximation
for
general metroid's matching
uh the the ocrs and this is also optimal
for for metroids of course
okay so this is not static thresholds
but it's a nice you know extension
and we'll see this come up again when we
talk about online resource allocation
questions at this point
no so this approach uh is not gonna give
you better than two for any setting yeah
it's like inherently it loses a factor
of two
okay so let's talk about online resource
allocation which i mentioned before is
slightly general uh
more general setting in that you know
we're not just accepting or rejecting
every element that arrives but this time
around we you know have a bunch of
resources and we have a bunch of
customers and now we actually need to
decide which resource to allocate to
which customer
so one way of thinking about this is you
know instead of in this matching setting
instead of getting you know an edge at a
time i'm now now getting you know
subsets of edges at the time so this is
the setting is easier than the
matching
profit inequality i
talked about before uh because you could
you know just
imagine that the edge you could just
pretend that the edges are actually
arriving one by one so we can certainly
apply that matching ocrs
uh but this is a simpler setting so we
can ask well can we do better than what
we can get for matching
and it turns out that we can and i'll
describe this very nice algorithm due to
feldman graven in this year and it's
also a direct extension
of
samuel khan's work based on the balanced
thresholds idea
so what we're going to do is we're going
to set a price for each item so i'll
index items by i
customers by j and w i j is the weight
of the edge i j
and we're going to set a price for each
item and this is just going to be
half of the expected contribution of
item i to the optimum so again i could
imagine computing the hindsight optimum
and i could ask well what is the
expected weight of the edge that got
matched to i
in that
hindsight optimum and that's that's that
quantity okay
and then what i'm going to do is when
every customer arrives
i'm going to match them to the item so
so j is the arriving person i'm going to
match them to the item that maximizes
this difference
so recall that on a previous slide i
called this the utility of the the
customer and this is precisely what it
is they're going to maximize
their value for the edge minus the price
for the corresponding item over whatever
is remaining at the time they arrive
will be right okay
so in terms of uh you know this has very
nice economic properties right so uh you
know i have prices and i i let the
customers do what they want at those
given prices and i just let the process
run at that point like in this 3d
fashion
and on the one hand i said that you know
you we have more information here than
the matching profit inequality but on
the other hand the algorithm is giving
up all of this control by letting the
shoppers you know choose what they want
to do and yet it turns out that we'll be
able to match
the
uh the factor of true for the single
item
profit and equality
using this and using much of the same
style of analysis that uh we saw for uh
samuel khan's uh result so this is
a really really nice uh
approach yeah i was just gonna ask the
the exact expression looks a little more
like the kleinberg weinberg like
yes yes like is there some interrogation
yes this
this is this was indeed inspired by
uh climber weinberg's approach and this
uh and they have a a balanced condition
uh that they define and that uh carries
over to this setting and do much more
general uh settings i'll very briefly
mention but uh thomas is somewhere in
the audience and there he is and his
work sort of makes that connection very
explicit and
so how do we analyze this uh well
let's look at uh
the contribution item i makes in the
optimum and and in the algorithm and
there should be expectations all over
but uh
will be a little imprecise about that so
let's say that i'll call the item that
customer i is assigned to in the optimal
i denoted by j star of i
and then when uh i'm going to look at
what happens to item i in the algorithm
so we'll again write this as the price
for item i times the probability itself
plus
we're gonna just look at the
contribution from
uh its matched customer j star of i when
j star arrives so when jstar arrives
if item i hasn't sold yet then jstar has
the option of uh of purchasing item i
okay and they will get this utility from
doing so
okay now uh you know jstar might go
ahead and decide to purchase something
else
they'll get at least so much utility
from purchasing that something else and
we'll just attribute this to item i so
whatever utility a customer gets in my
algorithm will actually get attributed
to the item they were matched to or not
and so this is the contribution of item
i to the algorithm
and now from here onwards it again
becomes straightforward because when i
take expectations
this becomes the probability that item i
didn't sell
uh
when it's uh you know matched customer
arrived which is at least as large as
the probability that it doesn't sell at
all
and
uh
and remember that you know ti was half
the contribution of i to up so
essentially
you know this this quantity is at least
as large as ti so i get this ti in both
the places and the probabilities add up
and i get half the contribution of i to
the r
so there are a few details that are
under the rug here but
this is essentially
what happens
okay and then uh as i said you know this
idea of uh
um you know uh balanced prices this
extends to
a number of different settings uh you
know you could imagine a bunch of
resources where customers have
combinatorial preferences over these
resources and now you can ask well can i
again come up with a pricing based
online allocation algorithm and turns
out that in many settings you can uh
but most
uh settings you do need some amount some
kind of sub additivity in the
preferences of the buyers
in this setting could you also do the
case when uh
like
you have general mate voice on the
left-hand side not only partition like
this here you have like a item arriving
and
you get to
see all that just to partition my
perspective like the general matrix on
the left
so um yeah that's a good question
um
yeah i i don't know so you say um
yeah what's been looked at is sort of um
uh you know different kinds of
value functions that will determine you
know what choice uh people make but they
can have um sort of different subsets of
resources uh as potential uh allocations
so uh as far as constraints go i don't
know if uh you know general metroid's
how they might impact the problem so
it's something i need to think about
yeah i'm pretty sure it works so i've
thought about this and it's pretty
straightforward
this can be expanded yeah so i guess uh
what ola is asking is if so you will
have to you know yeah make it precise in
some way right because the whole point
here is that you have multiple resources
so
uh and and multiple ways of um
satisfying each request is the the key
thing here so we'd have to somehow merge
that with the feasibility constrained of
whom can you satisfy so
you mentioned duels so are there any
results for
small inventories or lots of species
yeah so i this is like a small point at
the bottom so
i wanted to point out that normally when
you see this kind of quantity the
utilities show up in you know a certain
sort of market design and pricing
settings the prices come from those here
the prices very much don't come from
duels they're they're much impact in
general they're going to be much larger
than dual prices but with large
multiplicities and additional
assumptions sometimes dual prices work
mostly they don't work you're going to
fix them like the maximum
it's not clear how you would fix them no
but it's it's an interesting question to
think about yeah
okay so
let me move on so i have about 15
minutes left and i want to talk about
the secretary problem so this is going
to be a little bit quicker
okay so the secretary setting is uh
entirely different
or
somewhat different because now you know
we don't have these distributions
all we know and we have no idea you know
even what the range of values is all we
know is that uh you know these elements
are going to arrive in uniformly random
fashion and so uh in some way pretty
much the only thing you can do is to you
know observe a few elements to to get a
sense of what the the spread of values
is
right and so that's what uh the typical
algorithm for the secretary problem
looks like it's going to you know
just observe for the first few elements
and not take any action
uh and it's going to use these to learn
the instance essentially
and then from that point onwards it's
now going to move into an exploit phase
okay so for the single unit setting for
instance you could reject the first uh n
over two elements and then uh you know
that gives you a sense of what the
largest weight is and now you're gonna
in the exploit phase basically pick the
first thing that exceeds that that
threshold
and
uh one can see that the
uh here the probability that the
algorithm picks the largest weight
uh you know this happens uh at least in
the event where you happen to see the
second highest element among the first
half and then the highest element in the
second half because in this case your
threshold is going to be the second
highest rate and then the only thing
that crosses this threshold will be the
highest rate element
okay so uh you know very loose analysis
of course but this event happens with
probability at least one quarter uh and
so you know the optimum of course gets
the the largest weight we get this with
probability one quarter so this is a
four competitive algorithm
but you can do quite a bit better
you know it turns out that the optimal
thing here is to uh to stop the explore
phase at n over e elements and then you
can also provide a tighter analysis and
this gives an e-competitive algorithm
okay and now of course the questions we
should be asking
uh so some
colors don't show up but uh the the you
know the uh design parameters here
are you know how long should we be
exploring
what quantity or statistic do we want to
learn
in different contexts uh you know how
should we run the exploit phase what
kind of
algorithm do we want there
and you could imagine you know multiple
iterations of explore and exploit and in
different contexts you know different
combinations of these works so for
instance if we're in the k unit uh
setting then it's sufficient to just
explore for a much shorter uh phase uh
because if k is large enough very
quickly uh we get a
um
you know
high confidence uh estimate
of the largest values but in fact one
can do better so uh kleinberg showed
that
if you do this explore exploit idea in
geometrically increasing phases
where uh you know in every phase you're
going to
learn a threshold from the previous
phase and then pick all the elements
that cross this threshold in the next
phase
and done the right way this gives 1
minus 1 over root k
competitive
um for
general meteoroids
uh here's one approach you try to you
know just
figure out the right weight range to
pick elements in and again we're gonna
we'll select just a single threshold and
greedily try to pick as many elements as
we can uh that cross that threshold and
uh uh one can show that if it's a k rank
k metroid this gives a log of k
uh competitive algorithm uh
and you know one of the tantalizing
questions in this
uh
on this topic is whether
there's uh an of one competitive
algorithm for
uh the uh
for the for general metroid's in this
case and uh they're seeing a lot of work
on this
constant competitive ratios known for
special meteorites but the best known
for
uh general metroids is a log log k
and i was just told this morning that
there's been a nice uh um
work in this direction by uh sharon
dugne who showed a connection between
this metroid secretary problem
and
uh the metroid ocrs that we talked about
before except in order to get the
metroid secretary uh constant
competitive ratio you need to be able to
solve the ocrs for correlated
distributions we said you could get a
factor of two for independent
distributions for correlated
distributions
correlated distributions but random
order of arrival okay so
uh so maybe a question to attack this
semester with the number of experts here
in the audience
okay so i'll try to wrap up but i want
to mention uh
so going to online resource allocation
here i want to mention uh sort of two
different uh two other ideas that have
been uh explored in the literature
and the first one is
uh you know if we
write down the you know one of the
things so the question is if you see
let's say half the instance this is uh
you know uh a sample of uh half of the
you know elements that are going to
arrive
uh we could you know solve the problem
over that uh random instance and now
what is it that we want to learn from
that random instance to carry forward
into our uh exploit phase and one idea
for
uh for packing problems
is that you could you know write down
the dual and as i said before the duel
you know naturally gives prices uh over
the resources we have and i'm going
pretty fast here but happy to
describe this in more detail offline but
if you write the dual it gives these
prices for the different resources and
then we do the same thing
in the exploit phase where we let every
shopper you know pick the
utility maximizing item
and now one can again show that you know
if the
item multiplicities are large enough
then uh you know you can learn this dual
pretty well in this explore phase
uh so that uh you know
using concentration bounds
you
you can get uh competitive uh
competitive um
uh
uh
solutions for the from the slightly
so that's the dual learning approach
and
there's one last approach that i want to
mention which is uh due to thomas and
and co-authors
and that is a
very interesting idea that you know
instead of learning the dual and
worrying about all of that how about we
just learn the primals so what do we
mean by by you know learning the primal
uh what they suggest is the following
very simple algorithm it's it says well
at every step i'm gonna just look at the
instance i've seen so far
okay i'm gonna solve for the optimal
solution over this entire instance now i
can't do anything about the elements
that arrived previously those are you
know i've already made decisions for
those but i'll look at the very last
element and what this optimum from one
to i tells me about how to serve request
i and
i'm going to try to follow this optimum
to the best uh
of my ability so you know maybe this is
a fractional solution i'm going to round
this fractional solution and if it's
still feasible to uh you know add the
same solution that this gives me for the
ief type and i'm gonna add it okay so
like best effort and amazingly this
works and in fact it works better than
the dual learning approach and
uh there's uh there's a
very nice and simple analysis in
particular for the the matching setting
and i'm running out of time so i won't
go over it
but i
encourage all of you to read this 2013
paper it's a nice read
okay
so
uh just to wrap up these are you know
some of the different techniques i
talked about the two problems there are
lots of different connections between
these two different ways of coming up
with a semi-random model for
online selection
and
i want to really quickly mention
a few different variants that have been
studied this is a very very rich space
and there are you know 100 different
variants one could imagine so you could
you know imagine for instance uh that
you know there's maybe something extra
you know about the weights like their
iid so then you could hope to do better
or you know maybe
you weaken some of the assumptions
weights are correlated i'm going to
throw up a bunch of references here and
uh you know they're far from exhausted
and a lot of the authors are sitting
right here so
i apologize in advance if i miss your
relevant work but there's a lot of
beautiful work uh done very recently on
this topic
um then there's you know settings where
you have sample access to the
distributions
uh you could imagine playing around with
the order of arrival so maybe instead of
you know adversarial order of arrival
you're actually allowed to choose the
order in which you uh observe the
elements so this would be a best order
profit inequality or there are there's
work that looks at constrained settings
where you know the order is not fixed
but you have some constraint on how you
can visit the elements
um
non-uniform distributions over orderings
and then there's this
nice model that combines aspects of
profits and secretaries called profit
secretary so you know the weight
distributions but also the elements
arrive in random order
there are non-linear objectives that
have been looked at stochastic
departures it's just a lot of work in
this area and then i want to also
mention a few other broader directions
so these kinds of models of random
arrival of requests or you know known
distributions have been studied for a
number of other optimization problems
one other very neat direction is
settings where you can actually uh
you know pay some cost to
uh to find out how a
distribution is instantiated and these
are
called pandora's box problems uh or you
can you know
probe some of the random components for
free but you had some constraint on
which ones or how many you can prove
those are also really interesting
directions
uh that's it i'll take questions thank
you
[Applause]
we have a sense of uh
how does the competitive ratio depend on
the amount of uncertainty
that will occur in the future like these
are parametric competitive ratios
because
you know in one extreme if you know the
graph or you know the instance you know
you expect performing
so typically in these settings we uh
know the feasibility constrained ahead
of time so that's uh one aspect now
about the distributions
um so you're asking uh you know how
closely do i need to know the
distribution and there's a little bit of
work on
um
you know what if there are
errors in estimating distributions how
do these yeah you know translate into
worsening of the competitive issues so
um there's uh
work from a few years back by
uh paul duting and others on that
uh and and thomas sorry
actually someone tends to remember the
first authors only i just don't know the
distribution also matters if you have a
lot of spread versus like you know
some sort of possibility of the
distribution uh do you have uh thomas do
you have some insight into that um so
generally
all of this is actually always taking
the worst case over all distribution we
have one paper lx and i together on mhr
distributions
so assuming that you have a monitor and
has a trade then you can suddenly become
far better
i think that's the only
assumption comes up in many different
contexts and these are distributions
where the
median is close to the mean and that uh
you know
makes many things easier
that's a good question though uh and i i
you know i briefly mentioned you know
thinking about correlation so all of
this work assumes independence and it
kind of is a crucial uh assumption and
sometimes you know negative correlations
work out just fine uh but you know
thinking about models of positive
correlation where you can still get good
results that's you know that's a very
interesting direction
okay